schön dass sie dabei sind meine damen
und herren am tag der großen
eröffnungsfeier von peking die welt zu
gast bei freunden beziehungsweise bei
freunden die menschen unterdrücken und
keinen widerspruch duldet beispiel vom
tage heute wollten die athleten aus
taiwan den einlauf eigentlich schwänzen
weil china ihrem land mit zwangs
wiedervereinigung droht und weil sie ja
in peking nicht mehr unter ihrem namen
also taiwan auftreten dürfen trotzdem
hat das ioc die taiwanesen gezwungen
mitzulaufen und ja um diese fast
zumindest ein bisschen auszugleichen
folgt nun eine alternative
eröffnungszeremonie und zwar nur mit dem
team taiwan unter dem stolzen namen
taiwan und begleitet von der herrlichen
taiwanesischen hymne
wunderschönes
eigenständiges land
so ähnlich geht der text glaube ich ja
ich habe gehört peking findet das
irgendwie nicht gut wenn man taiwan als
eigenständiges land bezeichnet deswegen
dachte ich wir erwähnen mal kurz das
taiwan ein eigenständiges land ist mein
mitgefühl galt heute ansonsten vor allem
den eingeteilten jubel komparsen die da
über stunden den hampelmann machen
mussten würdelos motto wer nicht hüpft
der ist hey hey
junge junge junge das ioc unter seinem
deutschen präsidenten thomas bach hat es
also wieder mal geschafft die spiele in
eine lupenreine diktatur zu vergeben was
sagt man dazu we can say we did
da kannst du echt stolz darauf seinen
tommy aber wenn schon diktatur könnte
man nicht wenigstens einen nehmen wo es
öfter mal schneit es hat sich irgendwie
bewährt für winterspiele obwohl die
regierung in peking unter chronischem
wassermangel leidet werden dass die
ersten winterspiele nur mit kunstschnee
ein wahnsinn wenn da wo jetzt die
gigantische neue bobbahn steht war bis
neulich noch naturschutzgebiet worauf
das regime in peking gesagt hat ja dann
ist das jetzt eben keins mehr fertig für
eine bobbahn die nach dem spielen
wahrscheinlich kaum noch genutzt wird
sagen experten es gut außer von den
panthers die da vielleicht noch aus spaß
herunterrutschen das weiß man nicht
präsident lee hat seinem land verordnet
sagt wir sind ab jetzt eine
wintersportnation
und wenn der präsident das sagt dann ist
das halt so da machst du nichts machst
du nix winterspiele im schlimmsten
überwachungsstaat der welt warum warum
kriegt ausgerechnet peking zum zweiten
mal ein olympisches event hat noch
keiner gekriegt und natürlich wieder
kein wort vom ioc bis heute vom ioc und
seinem präsidenten bach zum schicksal
der uiguren oder zu eingesperrten
menschenrechtsaktivisten hier geht es
nämlich leider um etwas viel wichtigeres
meine damen und herren um eine
männerfreundschaft ja um romance
bach könnte sich doch wenigstens
schützend vor seine athleten stellen
denn auch den athletinnen und athleten
droht das regime in peking ziemlich
unverhohlen also dass hier jedenfalls
klingt für mich irgendwie bedrohlich
oder während eines wettbewerbs ist es
nicht gestattet seine ansichten zu
äußern bei pressekonferenzen oder
interviews schon aber die athleten
müssen wissen dass sie für ihre aussagen
die volle verantwortung tragen
jeder darf hier sagen was er will aber
ich würds lassen
chinesisch über 80.000 schriftzeichen
aber kein einziges für meinungsfreiheit
meine spätestens da bei solchen
statements muss doch das ioc man sagen
bis hierher und nicht weiter freunde
dieser absolutistische feudal verein zu
einem deutschen sonnenkönig bach
vor den ersten spielen in peking 2008
hat er immer getönt olympia wird den
wandel in china bringen ja der super
geklappt wenn man nicht jeder hat sich
gewandelt von einer diktatur in eine
absolute albtraum diktatur was bitte
erwartet das ioc trotzdem von peking
2022 auf gute menschen die sich die
hände reichen und
prinzen bauen
bei dieser organisation ist es darum
brücken zu bauen
wir errichten keine mauern nein das
machen die chinesen und zwar um die
arbeitslage der uiguren herum er ist
schon erstaunlich dass ich für diese
image katastrophen spiele trotzdem
sponsoren finden zum beispiel erdbeeren
wie offizieller sponsor was aber sogar
fast sinn macht denn die können jetzt in
china die ganzen leeren wohnung von
regimekritikern vermieten ebenso dabei
im peinlichen sponsoren reigen die
deutsche allianz versicherung ja die
allianz bietet sogar speziell für die
athletinnen und athleten in peking was
völlig neues an und zwar die sogenannte
haftpflichtversicherung
in china bei olympia
[Musik]
sprichst du das wort
uiguren aus sack ist die polizei schon
da
[Musik]
du kommst so schnell nicht mehr nach
hause
doch wenn du die
verpflichtung
holen wir dich wieder aus dem knast und
jetzt macht sport und sei schön still
weil thomas bach das gerne
eine allianz fürs überleben
allianz offizielles unser dieses einen
sport events dass in diesem land
stattfindet wo alles in ordnung ist
ja man könnte fast meinen olympische
spiele rechnen sich nur noch fürs ioc
und seine funktionäre und für
autokratien im rennen um 2022 waren am
ende tatsächlich nur noch china und
kasachstan
tolle auswahl ist aber kein wunder denn
von diesen veranstaltungen hat die
gastgeber bevölkerung in der regel gar
nichts außer kosten umweltschäden und
bauruinen getreu dem alten ioc motto
gewinne für uns verluste für alle zum
glück muss ich sagen zum glück senden in
diesen tagen ard und zdf sehr viele
beiträge zum thema menschenrechte in
china wirklich sehr viele möglicherweise
nur eine theorie ist auch ein mühl
schlechtes gewissen ins spiel weil es ja
weder das ioc noch die spiele da ohne tv
gelder geben aber klar völlig klar
wichtig ist dass man es anspricht also
zwischendurch die 19 thomas dreesen
kratzt oft install juni in den steilhang
und guthaben menschenrechte hat nur
minimalen rückstand an der ausfahrt free
tibet
nach einem langen gleitstück fliegt er
mit klar bester zwischenzeit über den
seitensprung und
rüstet sich dem ziel hat
die winterspiele 2022 da müssen wir
jetzt durch und schreibt mal live rüber
in unserer zdf studio in peking zum
sport kollegen albrecht humboldt der
aber offensichtlich noch gar nicht
albrecht
sind sie da ist ja
gott es ist so schön mit insulin ich
habe seit tagen mit keinem mehr geredet
wir werden hier total abgeschottet in
diesen überwachungsstaat ich kann es
nicht beweisen aber ich hab das gefühl
man wird ja gefehlt ja es ist ein
fernsehstudio ein recht sie haben doch
keine ahnung was hier los ist bei uns in
der olympia- babbel
die journalisten dürfen niemanden
treffen
rund 3000 athleten und medienvertreter
müssen sich für die gesamte dauer in
strict der abschottung begeben ohne
kontakt zur bevölkerung
so dürfen sie lesen olympia teilnehmern
unter anderem auch bei verkehrsunfällen
nicht helfen wirklich war sie dürfen uns
überfahren aber sie dürfen uns danach
nicht helfen und sie wissen immer wo wir
sind alle sportler und journalisten
wussten eine spezielle app aufs handy
laden damit man uns rund um die uhr
orten kann experten sagen damit haben
die chinesen sogar zugriff auf meine
audio und textnachrichten tippte also da
würde mich aber beschweren bei wem denn
sie ist doch keiner in dieser babbel
trifft man wenn überhaupt roboter sogar
in der kantine man bestellt sich was und
dann seilt eine maschine von oben dass
kunden ab egal was man bestellt es gibt
im balkonbau hühnchen und jetzt sag ich
mal einen satz von dem ich nie gedacht
hätte dass ich den mal sagen muss
dürften die stadt kontakt mit menschen
soll ein roboter helfen wenn hier die
athletinnen und athleten ankommen wo ist
die gepäckaufbewahrung
es sind viel zu viele menschen hier jaja
da tut sie ganz verständnisvoll weil der
roboter versagt hat aber soll ich ihnen
mal was verraten direkt danach haben sie
den blech kollegen natürlich
arbeitslager gebracht china nutzt die
spiele als fette propaganda show und wir
als zdf helfen mit ob wir wollen oder
nicht da nutzen auch keine noch so
kritischen berichten über menschenrechte
denn der quatsch hier wird schließlich
auch mit deutschen tv gebühren so
verdammt der polizei roboter
classical missverständlich
nottreppen
arschloch
da kommt das nächste kongo wünschen
welche ich muss schluss machen
ein bisschen weiter nach links
noch mehr
vorsicht vorsicht
versuchte scheiße
ich habe sowas von kein bock mehr
albrecht humboldt vielen dank
albrecht humboldt unser mann in peking
quizfrage wissen sie eigentlich wer
unter anderem offizieller ausstatter des
ioc ist der chinesische textilkonzern
anteil ganz genau der konzern der seine
baumwolle unter anderem aus der
uiguren-provinz shin young bezieht ioc
powered by zwangsarbeit es ist wirklich
alles nicht mehr zu glauben gernot
hassknecht verleiht einen preis den
keiner haben will
der aktuell peinlichste deutsche
überhaupt präsentiert wurden gernot
hassknecht
der ioc präsident thomas bach dankeschön
ich muss das begründen liegt doch auf
der hand der bach macht sich zum büttel
von diktaturen wenn man ihn auf die lage
in china anspricht sagt er die spiele
müssten zitat über politischen
differenzen stehen als wären
menschenrechte verhandlungssache der typ
ist sich original vor nix fies 0
berührungsängste sein fotoalbum ist das
who ist who der ganz bösen jungs ihr zum
beispiel verleiht er 2013 präsident sie
den orden wider den tierischen ernst und
wenn er aus versehen mal in der
demokratie vorbeischaut blamiert er sich
auch wie hier in australien die größte
musik musikalität liegt in meinem namen
das werde ich jetzt gleich beweisen
[Musik]
johann sebastian bach hat sich aus dem
jenseits gemeldet er möchte seinen namen
ändern weil er sich schämt bach ioc
nimmt im jahr geschätzte 1,4 milliarden
dollar ein wovon die athleten 4%
abkriegen über ihre nationalen verbände
den rest sagt die ioc mafia ein denn das
internationale olympische komitee ist
ein privat vor einer schweizer recht und
damit steuerbefreit wenn im strahl
trotzen endlich ungestört honig jedes
mal
und dann drücken sie den veranstaltern
auch noch knebelverträge auf die dafür
sorgen dass sie vor ort ebenfalls fast
keine steuern zahlen der olympische
geist hat sich vor lauter frust ins
privatleben zurückgezogen und ist
schwerer alkoholiker
ioc könnte man für so viel geld nicht
mal einen kritischen satz über china
fallen lassen einen kritiklos
chinesische propaganda erlegen so
erscheint das ioc unterbach von sheva
der wohl auch deshalb als guter freund
chinas gelobt und ihm eine büste
gewidmet
absolut angemessen die büste sieht aus
als hätte sie ein fünfjähriger aus
hundescheiße geknetet
ernsthaft ich kannte wochen lang
nachdenken mir würde kein einziger
lebender deutscher einfallen der mich
derartig aufregt
[Musik]
der aktuell peinlichste deutsche
überhaupt präsentiert wurden gernot
hassknecht
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]